et pour revenir sur cette réforme et la
grogne sociale qu'elle suscita net paul
vaste bergeal conseillère municipale de
mantes la ville et ancien député est
avec nous sur ce plateau one est peul
vaste bergeal bonjour quand je remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rt france alors vous avez un
long parcours en politique vous avez
donc un certain recul
quand vous voyez que il y a pas un
samedi sans une manifestation 63e acte
des gilets jaunes aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que cela vous évoque
eh bien je trouve cette situation
actuelle que votre posture réaliste nous
avons des français qui sont inquiets des
français qui sont en colère la france
est cul par dessus tête depuis les jets
les jaunes parce que le calendrier a été
très mauvais on a enchaîné les gilets
jaunes la réforme des retraites
ça évoque une situation absolument
invraisemblable alors qu'il ya quelques
temps les français étaient quelques mois
les français étaient majoritairement
pour une réforme des retraites à points
plutôt oui et aujourd'hui on constate
que la grève sans chaînes que les
manifestations s'enchaînent
même si elles prennent d'autres formes
et que le gouvernement persiste dans ses
rails à a continué à vouloir avancer à
marche forcée et ça ne pourra pas
continuer comme ça alors le gouvernement
l'assurance cette réforme il s'agit de
justice sociale pourquoi cette réforme
selon vous n'aimez pas compris comme tel
aujourd'hui on voit bien la colère
qu'elle suscite
elle n'est pas compris je crois parce
tout d'abord le gouvernement est parti
de la fin des régimes spéciaux
bon là dessus ce sont venus se greffer
le siphonage des retraites des avocats
l'hôpital qui est mis à mort
actuellement les fonctionnaires
notamment les enseignants dont on
s'aperçoit qu'ils sont très peu payés
sont parmi les moins payés d'europe donc
il va falloir rattraper pour qu'il n'est
pas une retraite qui soit vraiment
complètement décapité donc là dessus est
venue se greffer tout une foultitude de
de problème avec un manque de pédagogie
le manque de pédagogie qui a été
accentuée par par des informations
complètement contradictoire presque
disait monsieur de le voir ce que disait
monsieur philippe ce que disait la porte
parole du gouvernement
comment voulez vous que les français
dans un sujet sur un sujet aussi brûlant
qui nous touche tous
un sujet très compliqué qui n'a pas été
bien mesuré dont la pac n'a pas été bien
mesurer comment voulez vous que les gens
s'y retrouvent justement alors le
conseil d'état vous parliez d'un manque
de pédagogie
le conseil d'état lui a taclé la réforme
un vendredi on l'a dit réforme que le
conseil d'état juge inachevé comment
vous expliquez qu'il y ait toujours
autant d'interrogations autour de cette
réforme est encore aujourd'hui elle est
dans les tuyaux depuis deux ans dans le
rap les deux ans je pense qu'il ya eu
une succession d'erreurs de la part du
gouvernement
si le conseil d'état tacle sévèrement
cette cette réforme c'est qu'il ya quand
même des raisons c'est que le
gouvernement veut passer par ordonnance
même s'il ya un débat d'habilitation sas
et ses légumes de l'équipe du problème
il y a eu un manque de préparation
notamment sur la période de transition
la période de transition n'a pas été
bien évoqué n'a pas été bien étudié
l'impact entre l'âge pivot l'âge de
départ lâche déquilibre enfin bref c'est
un bazar innommable et les français
essayent parce qu'ils sont inquiets et
c'est pas ce ne sont pas des imbéciles
les français essaye de comprendre ce qui
va se passer pour eux non seulement pour
eux mais pour l'heure leurs enfants et
même les retraités moi-je arpentent les
rues de mantes la ville
élections obligent à longueur de journée
que lise justement les habitants vous
côtoyer quotidiennement en conseillant
municipalité nous sommes dans une ville
un peu particulièrement de sa ville mais
ça ne vous aura pas échappé mais je vous
dis ils sont en colère ils sont en
colère parce que ils ont l'impression
qu'ils sont maîtrisés que le
gouvernement est autiste qui n'écoute
pas ce qu'on leur dit
et quand on a une réforme aussi mal
embarquée que celle ci ce n'est pas
honteux de dire nous nous sommes trompés
nous avons mal mesuré l'impact
nous retirons projet que nous le
reprenons à la base et nous repartons
sur un autre pièce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui du gouvernement on repart en
reprend des négociations reprend tout à
zéro c'est au fond de l'eau dit oui
parce que je pense que les français sont
inquiets et en colère
et ça ne va pas se dissiper comme ça le
malaise est très profond
le sait c'est plus qu'un problème lié
aux retraite proprement dit à la réforme
des retraites mais c'est aussi un
problème qui débouche sur un problème de
conception de la société
alors comme le gouvernement nous dit
c'est un problème d'équité nous
l'entendons bien c'est un problème de
transparence sa chute je ne suis pas
d'accord
mais ce n'est pas très juste et ce n'est
pas transparent du tout mais il faut
quand même aller plus loi et voir que
notre société actuelle
elle est fracturée il ya une vraie
fracture et cela va se mesurer dans les
prochaines élections
alors y avait des derniers propos du
chef d'état également qui ont suscité
beaucoup de réaction le chef de l'état
qui a dénoncé les discours politique
extraordinairement coupable je le cite
martelant que la france est devenue une
dictature
ce sentiment le vois bien partagée par
certains de vivre dans un régime
autoritaire aujourd'hui est ce que vous
le comprenez les gens de votre commune
il vous en parle également
oui oui bien sûr ils m'en parlent
et moi en tant qu' il ya un regard sur
son histoire
je compare toujours un petit peu le
présent et le passé pour voir un peu où
l'on va et je comparerais la position
actuelle de notre pays et de ses
dirigeants
avec la fin du 19e siècle avec l'époque
de napoléon iii rappelez vous cette
dérive qui a eu le prince président qui
a dérapé progressivement vers un régime
je ne parlerai pas de dictature le mot
est excessif je parlerai simplement d'un
régime plus autoritaire beaucoup trop
autoritaire par rapport à ce dont la
france a besoin
il nous reste quelques instants
peut-être pour conclure vous le
rappeliez les élections municipales dans
moins d'un mois comment est ce que vous
voulez
gines et quelles perspectives à quelles
perspectives de ton s'attendre je pense
que là où il y aura des listes bien
identifié la république en marche il va
ya certains vont y laisser des plumes
les français il se trouve qu'il ya
concomitance pratiquement entre cette
révolte contre la réforme des retraites
et les élections municipales on est
quasiment en campagne je pense que ça va
forcément impacter sur les résultats
maintenant dans les villes où il n'y
aura pas vraiment de liste identifier la
république en marche mais où il y aura
des candidats de la république en marche
tout dépendra de la campagne que seront
les têtes de liste pour essayer
d'atténuer d'atténuer l'impact que cela
peut avoir des liens qu'ils ont avec
leurs populations
oui oui mais pas que moi je suis élu
depuis fort longtemps dans une dans une
ville de banlieue de la vallée de la
seine ce pas c'est pas simple mais c'est
une ville attachante avec des gens qui
ont besoin d'être con explique qu on est
con qu'on soutienne et cette situation
actuellement est une situation délétère
pour tout le monde
merci beaucoup à ned paul bass bergeal
d'avoir accepté notre invitation directe
ur été frange rappelle que vous êtes
conseillère municipale sans étiquette de
mantes la ville et ancien député merci